termina una semana de foro económico
mundial y entre las conclusiones que han
entregado las principales autoridades
económicas del mundo está que este año
pinta mejor de lo que parecía o de lo
que se esperaba hace unas semanas en
concreto la proyección de crecimiento
económico para este año es del dos coma
siete por ciento según el fondo
monetario internacional adicionalmente y
como parte de esto es que seguimos en un
periodo de policrisis este es el término
que han acuñado aquí Durante este
congreso de líderes y de políticos para
describir lo que es una alta inflación
combinada con altos endeudamiento de los
gobiernos y una guerra en Ucrania que
todavía sigue amenazando a la economía
adicionalmente también quedaron al
descubierto nuevamente las rencillas
entre la Unión Europea y sus socios Como
por ejemplo china a quien acusan de no
dejar entrar inversiones de su bloque
comunitario y con Estados Unidos también
por la ley de reducción de inflación que
para la la Unión Europea significa
una pérdida de competitividad de su
industria frente a la de Estados Unidos
finalmente el cambio climático fue gran
protagonista en la agenda de este
congreso de líderes los activistas
siguen incrédulos de que se puedan
encontrar soluciones en este escenario y
greta estuvo presente también con
manifestaciones en esta ciudad y en un
panel en el que pidió a las petroleras
terminar su extracción